thank you
[Music]
South Carolina woman gets 10 million
dollars after stepping on a rusty nail
at Walmart oh that's all you have to do
good for her dude why is there rusty
nails at Walmart that's why she got 10
million dollars
she brought that nail there and stuff
that's what I need to do yeah you know
how hard it is to get 10 million on
Krypton why is it Walmart's fall dude I
love this because at first when I first
read the title I was feeling the exact
same emotions just another piece of [ __ ]
the super envious I'm not getting 10
million myself wait is the story deeper
than that of course it's deeper but it's
way funnier to leave it at a shallow
Point like why the [ __ ] is there a nail
there that's all you have to do yeah you
hear all these stories of like [ __ ]
spilling hot coffee or some [ __ ] and
they get a billion dollars I'm like dude
[ __ ] someone run me over or something
dude someone spilled hot coffee on me I
got no money I got no stuff dude I saw
the hot coffee lawsuit though because
everyone's like oh my God what a [ __ ]
right but her she got Burns yeah where
was she I don't know what state but it
was a drive-through McDonald's or
whatever
with a t-shirt I don't know that's
actually the margin they use to get
around if the bird is like within the
T-shirt area like here and it wasn't
that's why she got so she's gonna be
fine going to an interview with a
Chinese parent it was her body but it
she looked like fried chicken though
what nationality was she I'm just
curious I think she's white yeah but
then they measured the white people use
suing as a tool you know I don't think
that's in our minds
Americans what was this lady I don't
know if they do it in Croatia as much
you know
American American that's good this
lady's name is April Jones she sued
Walmart after she was injured shopping
in a main aisle one of the company's
stores in Florence South Carolina in
June 2015. Jones had to undergo multiple
surgeries and eventually have her leg
amputated as a result of an infection
caused by The Rusty Nail jurors were
told during a five-day trial would you
lose your leg for 10 mils instead of a
[ __ ]
that's all you gotta do she likes it all
your legs were 10 million no no not my
legs okay one leg all right five million
is five what about a foot a foot how
much how much for a foot like from a mid
chin down 100 million I'd probably chop
off me and Below what about what if he
lost their name below for only 10
million no but because it actually looks
kind of tight in Instagram pictures dude
one of my homies one of my homies Casey
Mitchell shout outs to Casey his name's
the one they get monster he looks he's a
beast he looks kind of dope with one leg
he looks kind of dope but do you think
he would be down for two legs
he has one leg and he doesn't have a
hundred million I'll just saying yeah
but would you if you if you think it
looks dope with one would you be like it
don't match bro and then you just get
the other one out so then you can have
two two
not matching is a big deal 200 million
to get prosthetic yeah but then you only
have to buy one shoe at a time so you're
saving one no he wears both shoes you're
insensitive foreign
[Laughter]
no all you got to do is go to [ __ ]
amputee matchup right and then just be
like yo I got a right leg
yeah I got a right leg you got a left
leg and we'll go half C on the [ __ ]
wow that's great it's like a potato sack
race like a three-legging right yeah but
they gotta be the same shoe size
together so that's a rom-com dad that's
tight yeah yeah you gotta get yo yeah
you gotta is that a real sight probably
the same jacket it's going to be now you
want the same shoes this is the JK side
hustle so that guy said she had to
undergo multiple multiple surgeries
eventually had her leg amputated Jones
initially had to have her second toe on
her right foot amputated before three
most with three more toes were removed
and then doctors then had to amputate
her Legos so they just kept like going
yeah as it can as apparently the
infection continues to get worse and
spread and then she's actually been in a
wheelchair for the last six years and
has had to rely on on her adult children
why did it take her this long to get
paid out she deserves a payoff yes
that's the entire lawsuit slash like
medical everything like Kaiser
Permanente dude not like all the
surgical soldiers and all that stuff
like that's a lot of years of yeah not
being sure how it's gonna happen for how
long that took she should get more money
yeah I think so she's six years what was
a rusty nail doing at Walmart oh sure
that's her lawyer
what if it was like a construction
worker right and then that [ __ ] fell out
of his like shoe different insurance
claims I think
I think I think if you're in in the
field you don't even like the workers
the workers comps like covers that
especially if you're an employee but
since she's like a a civilian going to a
retail store that she doesn't have any
type of like entitlement over and stuff
like that I feel like that's way more
like there's a blame Factor you know
what I'm saying because then it come off
like a pallet or something like wood
could be oh that makes the most sense
the construction worker which is Nails
just rusty nails he collects and he just
drops them up or wherever he goes just a
bunch of nails just falling out wherever
he's walking the shoe got Nails in it
they do do that you ever like live next
to a construction zone you get flat
tires every month hell yeah oh really
yeah I had one time where uh I think my
mom was remodeling the back of uh her
house and then when I would visit like
almost every I got maybe three flat
tires within a month so it's your mom's
fault well it's a construction guy
[ __ ] throwing the nails out it's the
same dude
Rusty Joe
go to Walmart
a Walmart joke I think um yeah like what
we were talking about earlier Americans
and lawsuits are the thing like I know
but it's funner to be racist dude yeah
because it's like
so much fun that's what America's built
on the freedom to be just want to have
more fun dude with zero consequences
yeah that's pretty cool way more fun I
do feel like Americans like let's say
they're at Splash Mountain or a roller
coaster and the minute like their arm
gets stuck if it's not the first thing
they think about oh I get to sue Six
Flags
I don't know if that's like a thought in
any other country you know most other
countries are like oh oh everyone's like
oh are you okay I think America's oh are
you gonna Sue everyone's just about
suing yeah we gotta get someone who so
we can ask them the real questions like
someone that's been through that like
April Jones like I'm curious to see her
perspective on if it matches up with
what BART said it is [ __ ] like that
though I feel like you deserve more than
10 million yeah your life was ruined but
then you know the people that take
advantage though yeah they'll be like
whoa a banana peel and then they [ __ ]
fall on their butt and then they're like
well nothing happened but I was
traumatized give me 30 million that's
[ __ ] up dude I'm curious to see like
how many of those people actually get
paid out like the people that really try
to set it up like the like the Wendy's
finger in the chili person did they get
paid off they didn't they figured out it
was like their own severed finger or
something crazy wait what you talked
about it here I think yeah yeah I'm just
adding drama
play like whenever someone gets caught
for the fraud stuff they always look at
their record and they see that's like
the 20th time they've tried to pull this
like thing and they're like come on and
that's why you should never quit
whatever you draw what kind of fraud
you're trying to get never give up just
keep prodding the dude behind the the
Tesla cam who like pretends like when
the guy's pulling alley Falls over it's
like oh you probably love Teslas that's
why I love Teslas because they're always
freaking recording so it's saving a lot
of people a lot of problems nope there's
a thing called like Sentry mode or
whatever so if someone even just
approaches it turns on yeah that's tight
and they'll flash like a light on the
ground so it lets you know like hey I'm
awake [ __ ] dude that's tight I
saw somebody try to uh get a clan like
that they were crossing the street and
the guy was uh making a right turn this
big old truck but he was going really
slow and the guy that was crossing the
street apparently hit a bunch of papers
on I don't know why but he like threw
himself into the car and the car was
going like not even five miles an hour
he threw himself into the car and then
like flew and then a bunch of papers
flew up in there and he's on the ground
like yeah like it was like five of us
that saw and we're all like this
[ __ ] it happened to me last week
freaking homeless guy rode his bicycle
straight into my car oh our crosswalk
which car just a like a cord I try to
like say he was gonna Sue and stuff like
that yeah so he hit it like I just got
on it started saying
[Music]
I stopped at the at the crotch walk and
like this guy's riding his bike and he
just I'm like this guy gonna keep going
and he just goes whoa
he runs into my car and then he like
falls on the ground like the homeless
dude with a bike and all this trash and
then I just like looked at him I just
kept going and he's like wait
downtown yeah well of course he did but
what can you do you can't do [ __ ] if you
wanted you to probably get out and help
him and give him 100 you're gonna make a
big old scene and all that [ __ ] yeah I
feel like if people try to enjoy you it
should be law that that you don't have
to follow the law anymore yeah so like
if someone yeah
like if someone goes what
do that and you go okay [ __ ] and
then you back up and let them stand and
you ram your [ __ ] car into it if you
fake it you should be alone then they
fly up in the sky they come down and
they're pretty yeah and they're
paralyzed and you're like now you can do
a lawsuit [ __ ] that's nice man they can
enter the Lawless Zone yeah if you're
gonna put that on yourself yeah might as
well remember that dude that we did on
JK news where he fell backwards with his
ID in the [ __ ] backup camera and I
was a Tesla one whoa whoa
that's being prepared so happy yeah and
then you could go out in the back and
[ __ ] his ass up and be like now you can
sue me the homeless people in La they do
this thing
um where uh you know they go to you and
try to like wash your windows not just
LA but they do it everywhere but I feel
like I've been seeing this a lot lately
they uh try to wash your window and then
when you you're like oh no no I don't
need it they do a secondary version
where they tap your glasses if there's
something wrong with them right they're
like like trying to watch everyone
you're like no no they're like
right and they just started doing that I
remember the first time I was like oh
what's what's wrong and then they're
just like and come on I really need to
eat About Ballroom uh cool it's a
secondary bag it's a secondary hustle I
need to remember that last night
happened again
somebody comes up Nina's obviously
scared trying to wash the window I mean
no no that's cool he's just trying to
wash windows and he's like he's just
tapping on the glass like crazy come on
and I'm like
I know English
they usually [ __ ] up your windows I know
like it's not even clean they got
[ __ ] all that olive oil in the bucket
or something it's like it's even worse
sometimes I'll go hey you know what can
I just pay you and you don't even touch
my [ __ ] windshield dude yeah it gets
pretty bad but I mean
I don't know what they put in there it
is put it on my salad baby you know
what's hard every single time I have a
spare do you got do you guys care it's
like premium olive oil though nah no
nobody cares in case petty cash
some of them have like venmo and stuff
now too though hit me up no I don't
really know
no I've seen that though I've seen that
yeah scan my QR code I have cash now
here's my code yeah they're like using
my blockchain wallet
I take Bitcoin Hollywood homeless people
have venmo shines now I swear to God I
don't get asked anymore maybe because
they think I'm one of them
[Music]
foreign